last week President Trump spoke on the
phone with Russian President Vladimir
Putin now since then there's been a
rumor that the two have spoken on the
phone multiple times now this is
unbelievable to me
in this era but we so far the only show
that has gotten a hold of the audio of
those conversations here for the first
time are the phone calls between
Vladimir Putin and President Trump hello
no no this is love how are you wretched
[ __ ] Islands
hello use genetically modified orangutan
okay directory area Ukraine yeah we talk
business called serious stuff all the
way no question yes whose legs or need
to break to see him open oh I don't know
someone gay I guess it's rap you know
oh no thanks to them yeah babe lad guess
what I'm writing a voice without my
shirt or just like you know give that
you're making that sound with two
coconuts on that how did you know how
did I know
hahaha Ricky carry the microwave hey
Vlad you busy not the door not one sec
what is it okay in question at Accenture
of course what is it I got kitty glad I
need you to be totally straight with me
yes Donald I promise what is question
okay you know the towers of the Kremlin
they're all crazy colors with big swirly
tops are they ice cream yes I do it I
will send you some you [ __ ]
let's separate we did then and I know
you guys it's better Tetris and I'm
betting that you guys play that game at
least twice a day right yes yes we do
don't know we play Tetris all the time I
do it so cool yeah it is cool respective
pieces is before placing them exactly
where they need to be right we let them
pile up biding our time waiting for the
exact right moment yeah I know how that
just works well then when everything is
in place when the crusher is mounting
and it seems like everything is about to
end we drop the final pieces and bring
the whole thing down glad I said I get
it you rescue sure love over-explaining
videogames I know this you show up on
caller ID as recent purchase then blame
the missus on Obama Vlad you complete me
[Applause]
you